[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العناوين
ان شاء الله
اغلاق صناديق الاقتراع في تركيا ونائب
الرئيس يؤكد احترام الحزب الحاكم لنتائج
الانتخابات
في اعلان نادر موسكو تقر بمقتل اثنين من
قادتها العسكريين على خطوط الجبهه في
اوكرانيا
وطهران تبدي رغبتها في تطوير علاقاتها مع
القاهره وترتيبات للقاء الرئيسين المصري
والايراني
الخلافات بين قاده طالبان افغانستان تتسع
ومصادر تكشف عن رفض زعيم الحركه لقاء وزير
الداخليه حقا
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه من العربيه
نبدا نشرتنا من تركيا حيث يترقب الجميع ما
ستفرزه صناديق الاقتراع هذه الليله سواء
في الانتخابات الرئاسيه المفصليه وايضا
على مستوى الانتخابات البرلمانيه التي
تشهدها البلاد هذه الانتخابات التي ستغلق
صناديقها في او تغلق صناديقها في هذه
الاثناء وصفت بالمصيريه كونها ستحدد ما
اذا كان الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان سيواصل
حكمه الذي بداه قبل عقدين ام ان المعارضه
بقياده كمال كليتش دار اوبلو ستتمكن من
تحقيق المفاجاه
بالطبع هذه صور مباشره الان لبدء عمليات
الفرز
مع اغلاق صناديق الاقتراع في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه في تركيا عمليات
الفرز كما هو معروف في الانتخابات التركيه
تتم في امكنه صناديق الاقتراع ثم تعلن
النتائج ولكن غير الرسميه قبل منتصف هذه
الليله كما هو معروف اذا بدا عمليات فرز
الاصوات في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه في تركيا هذه المشاهد من احد
اقلام الاقتراع او صناديق الاقتراع في
مدينه اسطنبول حيث الثقل الانتخابي الاكبر
في هذه المدينه وبالطبع والتي كما يقال
سترجح كفه مرشح رئاسي على اخر وحتى تحالف
انتخاب برلماني على اخر اذن
بعض المشاهد من احد اقلام الاقتراع
وصناديق الاقتراع في مدينه اسطنبول لبدء
عمليات عد الاصوات او ما يعرف بفرز
الاصوات بعد هذه الانتخابات التي وصفت كما
ذكرنا بالمصريه
والمعلومات تشير الى ان نسب الاقتراع فاقد
كل التوقعات لا بل انها تشكل سابقه على
مستوى الانتخابات في تاريخ تركيا
والى شبكه بالطبع نحن ما زلنا مع هذه
الصور ولكن انتقل الان الى شبكه مراسلين
التي تتابع هذه الانتخابات منذ فتح صناديق
الاقتراع لابوابها وحتى اقفالها وصولا الى
اعلان النتائج معي من انقره مراسل العربيه
زيدان من اسطنبول مفردت العربيه كريستيان
بيسري ومن كهرمان مرعش موفد العربيه غسان
ابو لوز ابدا من اسطنبول حيث الثقل
الانتخابي الاكبر مع كريستيانو اهلا وسهلا
بك
ابرز ما لفتك حتى الساعه في عمليات
الاقتراع مع اغلاق صناديق الاقتراع الان
رئاسيا برلمانيا جديد المشهد وابرز ما
سجلته كاميرا العربيه كريستيان
اهلا بك يا طالب المشاهدين تعقيبا على
كلامك بالفعل يعني يقال هنا بان من يفوز
باسطنبول يفوز
بتركيا لانها فيها ثقل الاكبر لاعداد
الناخبين يعد هنا حوالي 11 مليون ناخب
وكما ذكرت ايضا في الخبر فقد
شهدت صناديق الاقتراع اقبالا كثيفا بالفعل
فكل التوقعات نتحدث عن حوالي 90% من نسبه
المسجلين فعلا ادلوا باصواتهم بسابقه في
تاريخ تركيا الحديث جميع الانتخابات هنا
مثلا مركز الاقتراع هذا سجل فيه حوالي
6000 ناخب وبالفعل قدم الى هنا واقترع
بصوته حوالي
5600 ناخب وبالتالي النسبه عاليه جدا
بالنسبه لملاحظاتنا
كان واضحا نوعا ما قله مشاركه العنصر
الشبابي في هذه الانتخابات بالمراكز التي
تنقلنا بها في اسطنبول التي تعد نوعا ما
ثقل الانتخابي لحزب العداله والتنميه
لاردوغان فان النسبه الاكبر من المشاركين
كانت من متوسطي الاعمار 40 وما فوق هؤلاء
يقولون بانهم يصوتوا لاردوغان بالرغم من
كل الاخفاقات في العامين الماضيين الازمه
الاقتصاديه وسوء اداره تداعيات الزلزال
وغيرها لانهم جيل شهد تركيا ما قبل حكم
اردوغان لها وما بعده وبالتالي عندما
يضعون الامور في ميزان كما يقولون فان
الدفه تميل لانجازات اردوغان وليس
لاخفاقاته المؤقته كما يقولون وما بين
تغيير وجه البلاد وتغيير يعني
ما يقولون بانه الطابع الاسلامي والمحافظ
لها الذي يحافظ عليها اردوغان وما بين
المعاناه اقتصاديا ولو بفتره مؤقته يفضلون
الازمه الاقتصاديه المؤقته على تغيير صوره
البلاد التي تمثل مبادئهم كما يقولون
ابقي معي سانتقل الى زيدان زنجلو هو معي
من العاصمه انقره زيدان اخر ما لديك وهل
يمكن تلمس اي مؤشرات الى من ذهبت اغلبيه
الاصوات في الدوره الاولى اتكلم عن
الانتخابات الرئاسيه املا هذا رجم بالغيب
ودونه محاذير زيدان
نعم شخص دخل في الكادر نعم بالفعل لا يمكن
التكهن الان
بنتيجه الانتخابات كل المؤشرات خلال
الايام والساعات الماضيه كانت تشير الى
تقارب كبير في حظوظ المرشحين الرئيسيين
نتحدث هنا عن
الرئاسه ما بين مرشح المعارضه كمال كلجدار
اوغلو وايضا مرشح الائتلاف الحاكم الرئيس
الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان بالعموم هناك
تقارب كبير لكن انا هنا ساشير الى نقطه
اشارتها زميلتنا كريستيان من اسطنبول فعلا
انا في المنطقه التي اتواجد فيها الان في
منطقه تشانكايا وهي منطقه
معروفه وداعمه لحزب الشعب الجمهوري هي
منطقه علمانيه اتتركيه ان صحت التسميه على
وجه التحديد لم نشهد كثيرا في المراكز
التي زورناها اقبالا من فئه الشباب فقط عن
المراكز التي زورناها ومشاهدات التي
رايناها
من مباشره في المراكز حقيقه المشاركه
الشبابيه في المراكز التي زرناها كانت
قليله وضعيفه نوعا ما لكن ننتظر النتائج
النهائيه لنعرف النسبه التي شاركت من
الجيل زد وهو وهي نسبه كبيره كان من
المفترض ان تشارك لكن في حال كانت
المشاركه ضعيفه من هذا الجيل من الجيل زد
هذا يؤشر الى ان الناخبين الشباب لم
يكونوا مقتنعين
بكلى الشخصيات التي ترشحت ونتحدث مباشره
هنا عن اردوغان اوبلو لاسيما ان فئه من
الشباب كانت تتطلع الى وجود وجه شاب وهنا
الحديث عن المعارضه وتحديدا الرئيس بلديه
اسطنبول اكرم امام اوغلو الذي نجح في
انتخابات البلديه عام 2019 ربما ننتظر لا
نريد ان نتكلم لكن نتحدث عن المشاهدات
الاوليه في حال كان هناك عزوف من فئه
الشباب فهذا ربما ما رده الى
خيبه امل الناخب الشاب بعدم وجود شخصيات
شابه من النقاط التي ذكرناها وذكرناها في
تقرير أنا صورته لقناه العربيه كان هناك
اقبال من الشباب على محرم انجا كان هناك
خيار بديل لاردوغان وكلي جدار اوغلو فئه
من جيل زيد كانت تفضل محرم ان جاء اولا
لانه اصغر سنا وهو يمتلك الحس الخطابي
الحماسي ويلامس احلام وتطلعات الشباب فئه
من جيل زيت كانت تتطلع التشخيصه يعني
ما
سمي التي وصفها بغير الاخلاقيه الى ما
هنالك ساعود اليك زيدان ولكن ارجو ان
تتفضل بالبقاء معي سانتقل الان الى غسان
ابو لوز هو معي من كهرمان مرعش غسان ابرز
ما سجلته في هذا اليوم الانتخابي الطويل
وهل بات من المفروغ منه ان الامور ذاهبه
الى جوله ثانيه على مستوى الانتخابات
الرئاسيه ام لا لا يمكن قول ذلك
طالب حتى اللحظه لا يمكن التنبؤ باي شيء
كان هناك اقبال كبير في هذه الولايه
كهرمان مارعش وفي المراكز الاقتراع التي
تجولت فيها لكن الذهاب الى جوله ثانيه
يعني حتى اللحظه من المبكر الحديث عن هذا
الامر خصوصا ان مراكز الاقتراع والصناديق
اغلقت قبل دقائق من الان وستبدا عمليات
الفرز وخلال الساعات المقبله ستتضح ملامح
المشهد الانتخابي بالضبابي في ظل هذا
التنافس الشديد والاستقطاب الكبير الذي
مرت فيه البلاد طيله الاشهر الماضيه في
كهرمان مرعش طالب هناك 750 الف ناخب يحق
لهم التصويت حيث نقف في هذا احد في احد
هذه المراكز وكما تشاهد من خلفي هناك
كرارفانات وضعت لاجراء عمليه التصوير
التصويت والاقتراع في هذه الكربونات بسبب
بان هذه المدرسه التي نقف بالقرب منها
تعرضت للزلزال وهي قايله للسقوط يصلح
للاستخدام البشري وبالتالي وضعت هذه
الكرفانات لاستقبال
المصوطين والناخبين في هذا المكان بحسب
اللجان هنا ابلغونا ان هناك كان اقبال
كبير وشديد جدا على هذا المركز او على هذا
الصندوق في هذا الموقع وايضا كان هناك
اقبال كبير في المراكز الاخرى التي على
الاقل زرتها انا واطلعت عليها وشاهدتها
وراقبت حركه الناخبين يعني كان هناك حركه
من الشباب بالنسبه لتلك المراكز وكان ايضا
هناك حركه من كبار السن ومتوسطي الاعمار
كانوا مقبلين على هذه الانتخابات
وتفاوتت مواقف هؤلاء حول المرشحين منهم من
صوت لاردوغان كما قال بانه يريد ان يحافظ
على هذا الارث لحكومه اردوغان ولرئاسه
اردوغان طيله الفتره الماضيه العشرين سنه
الماضيه ومنهم من يريد التخلص من حكومه
اردوغان والرئيس اردوغان وبالتالي الذهاب
نحو يعني كالجدار اوغلو وانتخاب كل جدار
اوغلو وكما قالوا هؤلاء انه انهم يريدون
التغيير ويريدون الديمقراطيه وايضا يريدون
العداله هناك فئه اخرى تبحث لم تفصح عن
شخص المرشح الذي انتخبته لكن كانت واضحه
بانها تريد حياه افضل وتريد تحسين المستوى
المعيشي تتحدث عن وضع اقتصادي صعب عن تضخم
وعن انهيار الليره او ارتفاع يعني قيمه
الليره امام الدولار وايضا اضافه الى ذلك
تاتي كارثه الزلزال التي فاقمت من معانات
هؤلاء الموجودين ونتحدث عن اكثر من ثلاثه
اشهر مرت على كارثه زلزال ولا مازال
المتضررون موجودون في الخيام وموجودون في
الكربونات طالب وهم يعني يطالبون السلطات
بالاسراع لكن نحن الان في
استحقاق انتخابي وبانتظار النتائج المقبله
وعلى بطبيعه الحال طالب يعني ايا كان من
سيفوز بهذه الانتخابات سيواجه صعوبه في
مواجهه ملف تداعيات كارثه الزلزال بسبب
الحجم الهائل الذي ضرب زلزال الذي ضرب هذه
المناطق نتحدث عن 500 كيلو متر مربع عن 11
ولايه عمليا طالب او تاريخيا هذه الولايات
تحديدا ولايه كهرمان مرعش ولايات اخرى هي
تاريخيا تصوت لحزب العداله والتنميه لكن
كما قلت سابقا في ظل الاستقطاب السابق
الشديد والمنافسه الشديده حتى الان المشهد
ضبابي جدا وما زلنا يعني بانتظار النتائج
التي ستصدر عن صناديق الاقتراع وصناديق
الاقتراع ستجيب عن هذه الاسئله التي
يمتدرها عموم البلاد
غسان كريستيان وزيدان والله اسمائكم لحسن
الحظ على نفس القافيه يعني ابقوا معي
ساعود اليكم بعد قليل اعزائي المشاهدين
توزعت العمليه الانتخابيه في تركيا على
اكثر من 190 الف صندوق اقتراع اذ هناك 60
مليون المناخب مسجلون بينهم نحو خمسه
ملايين ناخب يشاركون لاول مره في التصويت
اي ما يقرب من ثمانيه بالمائه من الناخبين
اما الشباب فيرى الكثيرون انهم اكبر
مجموعه من الناخبين المتارجحين اما
الاكراد الذين يمثلون ما يتراوح بين 15
و20% من اجمالي ناخبين فينظر اليهم على ان
لهم دورا محوريا في هذه الانتخابات
حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي الموالي للاكراد
ليس جزءا من تحالف المعارضه لكنه يناصب
اردوغان معارضه شديده على خلفيه حمله قمع
استهدفت اعضائه
وتجري الانتخابات التشريعيه على 600 مقعد
حيث يخوض السباق 24 حزبا سياسيا ومئه واحد
151 مرشحا مستقلا وجرت الانتخابات وسط
اجراءات امنيه مشدده حيث قال وزير
الداخليه التركي ان اكثر من 600 الف عنصر
امن تولي مهمه التامين الانتخابات
[موسيقى]
اعود الى شبكه مراسلين الذين يغطون هذه
الانتخابات المفصليه والتاريخيه في تركيا
كريستيانو من اسطنبول النتائج الليله الكل
سيقبل بها كما قال او كما يعني صرح اي ان
تكن النتائج هل الامور تشي بالنسبه اليك
من خلال متابعتك على الاقل على المستوى
الانتخابات الرئاسيه ان الامور ذاهبه
باتجاه دوره ثانيه هذا واحد اثنين على
المستوى الانتخابات البرلمانيه هل من
مؤشرات يعني تشير الى فوز تحالف
بشكل او باخر على الاقل في اسطنبول ام لا
لا يمكن رصد مثل هكذا مؤشرات
يمكن الحديث عن او الحديث عن نتائج
الانتخابات البرلمانيه اكثر من نتائج
الانتخابات الرئاسيه البعض هنا يقول بان
المعارضه يمكن ان تتقدم بالانتخابات
البرلمانيه وبالتالي حتى لو فاز اردوغان
ستكون مهمته صعبه من حيث تشريع القوانين
ولكن فيما يتعلق بالانتخابات الرئاسيه لا
احد يمكن ان يتكهن بنتائجه حتى يعني الكل
يقول بانها ستكون مفاجاه نحن هنا بدات
عمليه الفارس من المتوقع بعد ساعتان يعني
بحوالي السابعه مساء بتوقيت تركيا ان يبدا
اعلان النتائج الاوليه يعني نتائج
النهائيه والرسميه تعلن بعد يومين ولكن
يكون هناك نوعا ما اجواء الى من
ستذهب يعني او من سيفوز بهذه الانتخابات
يعني استطلعنا اراء ليس فقط المواطنين
وانما حتى المسؤولين الى مراكز الاقتراع
التي جلنا عليها
تعرف طاهر بانه باحوال مماثله بعمليات
الانتخابيه يكون هناك نوعا ما حرب نفسيه
وبالتالي كان
مسؤولو العداله والتنميه يقولون باننا
سنفوز بهذه الانتخابات كل المؤشرات تدل
على ذلك وكذلك مسؤولية المعارضه كان لديهم
نفس
التصريحات بانهم هم سيفوزون بهذه
الانتخابات وبالتالي من الصعب التكهن
بالنتائج ولكن باسطنبول على الاقل
بالاحياء التي
جلنا فيها التي تفقدنا مراكز الاقتراع
فيها النسبه الاكبر من الذين صوتوا كانت
لحزب العداله والتنميه بحكم ان ثقل
الانتخابي للرئيس اردوغان هنا في هذه
الاحياء في اسطنبول كريستيان يبقى معي
دعني اعود الى زيدان زيدان في العام 2017
يعني صحح لي اذا كنت مخطئ حول رجب طيب
اردوغان النظام السياسي في تركيا من
برلمان الى رئاسي مركزي في حال خساره
اردوغان هذه الانتخابات يعني لنفترض في
حال خساره الرئيس اردوغان هذه الانتخابات
هل تمت حديث عن العوده الى النظام
البرلماني من قبل مرشح المعارضه كمال
كريتشدار اوغلو ام لا لا وجود لمثل هكذا
كلام
نعم هو برنامجه الانتخابي لزعيم المعاضه
كمال كل جدار اوغلو العوده الى النظام
البرلماني وهناك مرحله انتقاليه
ستكون فاصله ما بين الانتقال من النظام
الرئاسي الذي جرى الاستفتاء عليه كما
تفضلت في عام 2017 في شهر نيسان شهر نيسان
ابريل 2017 الى النظام البرلماني المعدل
بحسب ما يقول زعيم المعارضه التركيه لماذا
المعدل لان شريحه كبيره من الناخبين
الاتراك يخشون
الاخطاء التي كانت موجوده في النظام
البرلماني السابق والذي ادى ويسمونه نظام
الحكومات الائتلافيه التي ادت الى
انهيار تلك الحكومات الى ازمات سياسيه
واقتصاديه عنيفه عصفت بالبلاد لذلك كلجد
كان يعد بالعوده الى النظام البرلماني لكن
المعدل والمعزز لتلافي تلك الاخطاء
هفوات التي كانت في النظام السابق
وبالتالي عدم تشكيل حكومات ائتلافيه لكن
على الطرف المقابل هناك من ينتقد كالجدار
اوبل ويقول بان تحالفه تحالف الطاوله
السداسيه هو شكل جديد هو النسخه نسخه 2023
من تلك الحكومات الائتلافيه باعتبار انه
ست زعماء من سته احزاب من من مختلف
التيارات سواء محافظين او قوميين او يمين
وسط او يسار هناك اليه وضعتها الطاوله
السداسيه وتوافق عليها زعماء الطاوله
السداسيه لانه عند اختيار او عند القرارات
واتخاذ القرار يجب ان يكون القرار
بالتوافق وهذه حقيقه مشكله ادت في
الاختبار الاول وهو اختيار المرشح مرشح
المعارضه كمالكلو الى انسحاب ميرال اكشنر
من الطاوله السداسيه ثم العوده لذلك
منتقدوك الجدار اوغلو يغمزون من هذه
الزاويه الى ان الطاوله السداسيه او فكره
الى النظام البرلماني ربما ضررها اكثر من
نفعها بينما مؤيدوك الجدار اوغلو يقولون
ان زمن الفرد الواحد في اشاره الى الرئيس
اردوغان يجب ان يتغير وان تعود البلاد الى
نظام برلماني له سلطه كامله وان يكون
الرئيس بمنصف فخري طيب زي
[موسيقى]
دان سيرين الى هذه الانتخابات اعزائي
المشاهدين من جانبه اكد النائب الرئيس
التركي فؤاد اقطاي ان حزب العداله
والتنميه الحاكم سيحترم نتائج الانتخابات
اي ان تكن واضاف ان الاقبال على التصويت
في الانتخابات الرئاسيه كثيف جدا مشيرا
الى ان هدف حزب العداله والتنميه ان تكون
هذه الانتخابات نزيهه وشفافه
الديمقراطيه والحداثه
والتعليل البلاد
اولئك الذين يستمعون الى هذا يمكنهم
بالفعل تخمين من هو
جئت للتصويت اعتقد ان الاقبال سيكون
مرتفعا الشخص الذي سيفوز في الانتخابات
سيفوز بفارق ثلاث او اربع نقاط
هذا العام مهم جدا السنوات السابقه كانت
ايضا مهمه جدا ولكن الان نحن كشعب سئمنا
من بعض الاشياء لا اريد الخوض في هذه
القضايا لكن هناك مشاكل باقتصاد البلد
واشياء كثيره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذهب الى غسان ابو العزه في كهرمان مرعش
غسان في حديث عن مسالتين اساسيتين في
المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال
يعني كهرمان مرعش يعني كانت من المدن او
الولايات التي ضربها الزلزال بشده وان
تداعيات الزلزال كانت حاضره تماما في هذه
الانتخابات اضافه الى موضوع اللاجئين
السوريين او النازحين السوريين هل فعلا
شكل هذان العاملان هويه في هذه الانتخابات
وفق متابعتك ام لا يعني الاولويات كانت
للاقتصاد للبطاله ولغيرها من الامور
لكل هذه الامور طالب بالفعل كان هذان
الملفان موجودين يعني نحن تابعنا مع
الناخبين الذين كانوا يدلون باصواتهم ثم
نخرجهم ونسالهم نسالهم لماذا لماذا
تنتخبون وماذا تريدون من المرشح او الرئيس
المقبل احدى الفتيات قالت بانها لا تريد
ان ترى السوريين في كهرمان مرعش عشر سنوات
يكفي عشر سنوات لوجود السوريين في كهرمان
مرعش وبالتالي هي لا تريد وجود السوريين
في كرمان مرعش مثل هذه الفتاه ينطبق عليها
الكثير في كهرمان مرعش وفي ولايات اخرى
ايضا اضافه الى ملف تداعيات الزلزال ايضا
سيطرت على المشهد الانتخابي في هذه
الولايه وفي جميع الولايات بطبيعه الحال
طالب هناك مطالب من المواطنين تحديدا من
المواطنين المتضررين والذين ما زالوا
لغايه الان يعيشون في الخيام ويعيشون في
الكربونات قبل قليل كنا عند احد مراكز
الاختراع كان هنا مركز اختراع في مدرسه
وبالقرب منها في س خاليه كان هناك لحدود
20 خيمه موجوده ما زالوا مقيمين في هذه
الخيام منذ اكثر من ثلاثه شهور وبالتالي
مثل هؤلاء الاشخاص الان يبحثون عن الملاذ
الامن يبحثون عن المنازل يريدون هذه
الحياه الكريمه ويطالبون السلطات بتامين
هذه الحياه الكريمه
فهذا يعني شكل ضغط على بالنسبه للمواطنين
الموجودين في كهرمان هلا هذا غير من
توجهاتهم او من
سنكون معك مع باقي الزملاء في النشرات
لاحقه وفي تغطياتنا اللاحقه
لمجريات العماليه الانتخابيه مع بدء صدور
النتائج في الساعات المقبله غسان ابو لوز
من كهرمان مرعش شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا ايضا
لكريستيان بيسري كانت معي من اسطنبول
وايضا من انقره مراسل العربيه زيدان شكرا
جزيلا لك زيدان
نشاط الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
اسرائيل تعيد فتح المعابر الحدوديه بشكل
جزئي مع قطاع غزه بعد اغلاق دام خمسه ايام
اهلا بكم من جديد نكمل نشرتنا من اوكرانيا
حيث اعلنت روسيا مقتله اثنين من قادتها
العسكريين في معركه بالقرب من مدينه بخموت
شرق اوكرانيا حيث تدور معارك شرسه منذ
اشهر وهذا اعلان نادر جدا لموسكو بشان
خسائرها في ساحه المعركه وقالت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه في بيان لها ان قائد
اللواء الرابع للبنادق الاليه ونائب قائد
فيلق الجيش للعمل العسكري والسياسي قتل في
القتال الدائر على خط الموجه
في هذه الاثناء اكدت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
في بيانها ان القوات الروسيه صدت جميع
هجمات القوات الاوكرانيه في منطقه باخمد
الوزاره قالت ان القوات الاوكرانيه بذلت
محاولات كبيره لاختراق دفاعاتها في
المدينه خلال الساعات الاربعه والعشرين
الماضيه
وفي سياق اخر اعلنت الدفاع الروسيه عن
احباط هجوم اوكراني في دونتس تكبدت على
اثره القوات الاوكرانيه خسائر بلغت 200
جندي بين قتيل
وجرح
تفكير في اتجاه سوليدار متواصلت مفارز
الهجوم بدعم من وحدات القوات المحموله جوا
القتال من اجل الاستيلاء على الاحياء
الغربيه خلال اليوم الماضي قام العدو
بمحاولات اختراق دفاع قواتنا في شمال
وجنوب باخموت لكن تم صد جميع الهجمات ولم
يسمح باي اختراقات في صفوفنا وتم تكميد
المهاجمين خسائر كبيره
هذا وذكر صحيفه ان مجموعه الدول الصناعيه
السبع الكبرى والاتحاد الاوروبي سيحضران
واردات الغاز الروسيه عبر المسارات التي
قطعت فيها موسكو
وقالت الصحيفه ان القرار المرتقب سيمنع
استئناف صادرات الغاز عبر خطوط الانابيب
الروسيه الى دولا الى دول مثل بولندا
والمانيا
اذ قطعت موسكو الامدادات عن هذه الخطوط في
العام الماضي
تصعيد مجموعه السبع والاتحاد الاوروبي حول
واردات الغاز الروسي يقابله تصعيد اخر من
كييف ربما لم يحدث بعد حيث كشفت صحيفه
واشنطن بوست ان الرئيس الاوكراني
خطط خلف الابواب المغلقه لشن هجمات على
اراضي روسيا وتعطيل خط الانابيب الذي يتم
من خلاله مرور النفط من روسيا الى المجر
عبر خط انابيب دروغبا حيث يتدفق من هناك
الى سلوفاكيا وتشيكيا لكن لماذا المجر
فرغم ان بودابست عضو في حلف الناتو الا
انها من اكثر الدول الاوروبيه تقاربا مع
وفقا لوثائق مسربه للبنتاجون حصلت عليها
الصحيفه فان زيلنسكي لم يتخلى عن فكره ضرب
اهداف داخل الاراضي الروسيه باستخدام
صواريخ بعيده المدى بالرغم من تاكيداتك
كيف بانها لن تستخدم الاسلحه التي تحصل
عليها من الغرب لاستهداف الاراضي الروسيه
اما واشنطن فهي الاخرى قلقه من خطط كييف
بشان توسيع نطاق الحرب لتشمل استهداف
الاراضي الروسيه وهو ما يفسر رفضها
المستمر في امداد كيف بصواريخ طويله المدى
حيث لا ترغب واشنطن في تحول المواجهه مع
موسكو الى مرحله جديده قد تصاعد من حده
الصراع
وفي اول رد فعل منه قال الرئيس
الاوكرانيس في خلال زيارته الى برلين قال
ان اوكرانيا لا تهاجم الاراضي الروسيه
وانها تكتفي بالسعي لتحرير اراضيها
لا نهاجم الاراضي الروسيه نحرر ارضنا
الشرعيه ولسنا معنيين بمهاجمه الاراضي
الروسيه ليس لدينا وقت ولا صلاحيات لذلك
ليس لدينا فائض من الاسلحه لذلك نحن نركز
على التحضير للهجوم المضاد لدحر الاحتلال
وفقا للقانون الدولي ووفقا لقانوننا
ودستورنا لانهاء احتلال اراضينا كما يعترف
بها العالم باسره
وعلى هامش زياره هي الاولى ليزالينسكي الى
المانيا منذ بدء الحرب اظهر الرئيس
الاوكراني انفتاحا على مباحثات سلام ولكن
فقط بشروط كيف من جانبه اكد المستشار
الالماني اول ان دعم برلين لكيف سيستمر
لاعوام قادمه واضاف شورس ان المانيا ستقدم
حزمه دعم جديده لاوكرانيا بقيمه تصل الى
ثلاثه مليارات دولار مشددا على ضروره
التقديم المسؤولين عن الحرب في اوكرانيا
الى العداله
الى برلين تنضم الي مراسله العربيه راغده
بهنام راغد اهلا وسهلا بك ما الذي حمله
الى القياده الالمانيه وفق متابعتك راغده
ما الذي سمعه وهل رشح اي شيء عن هذه
الانتخابات سوى الحديث عن موضوع المساعدات
اهلا بك يعني في الواقع
هناك
في المؤتمر الصحفي المشترك الذي عقده مع
المستشار الالماني حول المقاتلات التي
تطالب بها كييف منذ فتره وتعلم بان
المانيا ترفض تزويد اوكرانيا الان
بمقاتلات حربيه
قال بانه الان هو يعني يعمل على حلف
اوروبي او على حلف يعني لدى الدول الحليفه
لاوكرانيا لتزويد كياف بمقاتلات ولكن لم
يعلق على هذه النقطه تخطاها
ليعدد المساعدات العسكريه التي تقدمها
المانيا الان الى اوكرانيا ذكر بانه
المانيا الان باتت يعني الدوله الثانيه
التي تقدم مساعدات عسكريه لاوكرانيا بعد
الولايات المتحده ذكر يعني حجم هذه
الاسلحه ما هي هذه الاسلحه التي تقدمها
وايضا كان هناك تشديد تعليقا على ما ذكرته
قبل قليل عن تعهدات اوكرانيا بانها لن
تقصف اراد روسيه كان هناك سؤال من صح
اوكرانيه بما اذا كان هناك شروط محدده
لهذه الاسلحه التي تقدمها المانيا منها
عدم استهداف الاراضي الروسيه قال زيلينسكي
بانه الان تركز اوكرانيا على الدفاع عن
اراضيها لا تخطط ان تقصف الاراضي الروسيه
وهنا عقبه لاقول هدف هذه المساعدات هو
الدفاع عن اوكرانيا وتمكينها من ان تدافع
عن اراضيها يعني
لصد هذا الهجوم وليس ان يكون هناك هجوم
اخر لذلك ربما هاتين نقطتين هما اهم ما
خرج مخرج عن هذا اللقاء الثنائي ولكن تعلم
بان هذا اللقاء هو ايضا يعني هو لقاء
للتاكيد على انه هذه العلاقات الالمانيه
الاوكرانيه الان في مرحله جيده بعد فتره
من التوترات التي سبقت في الاشهر الماضيه
ما تراكي
عن المعلومات التي المعل التي تردنا انه
سيتوجه الى باريس بعد برلين في زياره هي
الثانيه له منذ بدء الحرب الى العاصمه
الفرنسيه هل تم التراجع شعبي من خلال
متابعتك راغده يعني تراجع شعبي الماني
كبير لمساله الدعم الذي تقدمه المانيا الى
كيف انه هذه التكلفه الان يعني حديث عن
ثلاثه مليار دولار يعني الشارع الالماني
ما زال وراء الحكومه في هذا الدعم ام لا
في تملم كبير باختصار
ربما التلكؤ الذي نراه من الحكومه
الالمانيه هو بسبب الاستطلاعات الشعبيه
لانه هناك انقسام في الحقيقه هناك تاييد
لاستمرار التاييد العسكري
لقياف ولكن هناك تردد في ما هي هذه
الاسلحه مثلا حول المقاتلات هناك انقسام
في الراي الشعبي ما اذا كان يجب تقديم
مقاتلات حربيه ام لا حول الدبابات ايضا
وكان الدبابات ليوبارد كان هذا سبب تردد
الحكومه الالمانيه في اعلان تقديم هذه
المساعدات لانه دائما الحكومه هنا تعتمد
على ما هو حجم التاييد الشعبي لاتخاذ
قراراتها هناك ما زالت ايد شعبي ولكن ربما
هذا يعني الاراء منقسمه بشكل او باخر وهذا
ما يجعل برلين ربما متردده
هذا ساكتفي بهذا القدر من برلين مراسلات
العربيه راغده بهنام شكرا جزيلا لك راغده
على هذه المتابعه
[موسيقى]
ست تطورات بالاراضي الفلسطينيه نقلت وسائل
اعلام اسرائيليه عن رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو قوله ان العمليه العسكريه التي
شنها الجيش الاسرائيلي واستمرت لخمسه ايام
قضت على قاده حركه الجهاد الاسلاميه حسب
تعبير وقال نتنياهو خلال جلسه لمجلس
الوزراء ان العمليه حققت اهدافها حيث غيرت
المعادله في غزه من خلال القضاء على
قيادات حركه الجهاد الاسلاميه بكاملها
لقد قمنا بتدمير 17 مركزا لقاده الجهات
وقتلنا عشرات الارهابيين قصفنا منصات
الصواريخ والقذائف وقضينا على فرق
الصواريخ المضاده للدبابات وغير ذلك اليوم
اعداء اسرائيل في غزه وغيرها يعرفون انهم
حتى ولو حاولوا الاختباء سنصل اليهم متى
نريد
هذا وظهرت مقاطع مصوره حجم الدمار في قطاع
غزه جراء الغارات الجويه الاسرائيليه
الاخيره
[موسيقى]
وفي اعقاب قرار وقف اطلاق النار بين
الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين اعادت اسرائيل
فتحه معبر بيت حنون وكرم ابو سالم المؤدي
الى قطاع غزه بشكل جزئي وتدريجي وبحسب
البيان فان الفتحه الكامل للمعابر سيكون
ممكنا بعد اجراء تقييمات جديده للوضع
وكانت حركه حماس قد حذرت من اغلاق محطه
الكهرباء الوحيده في غزه في حال استمرار
غلق المعابر الرئيسيه
كان قبل يعني اشي يعني
مؤلم للجميع واشي يعني
بخربط اركان الحياه وبيخلي الحياه ما فيها
اي حياه يعني
وبعد الحرب يعني الاشي بصير حلو وجميل
يعني الناس بتنزل بتتنفس يعني عائلاتها هي
قاعده على البحر
وبتشم الهواء وبتتنفس وكنت معتادا يعني في
ما قبل التصعيد انه اقوم بممارسه الرياضه
بشكل يومي صباحا في الفتره الصباحيه على
شاطئ بحر غزه ولكن نتيجه هذا التصعيد الذي
حصل من يوم الثلاثاء الماضي وحتى بالامس
لم نتمكن نهائيا من الخروج من بيوتنا
التصعيدات وحروب صاروا احنا شعب يعني
بالحب الحياه
فمن حد ما صارت التهدئه وصارت الهدنه
فبدنا نحاول نعاود نسترجع
النشاط التجاري تبعنا
نشاط الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
مواطن سعودي يلتقي والدته بعد فراق دام
اكثر من 30 عاما
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الى نشره الخامسه من
العربيه اجتمع قاده ارمينيا واذربيجان
اليوم في بروكسيل لاجراء محادثات على
خلفيه توتر على الحدود بين البلدين هذا
التوتر المستمر منذ حوالي 30 عاما للسيطره
على منطقه ناغورني كارباخ
وتجري هذه المحادثات غداه جديده على
الحدود فقد اعلنت يرافان قبل يومين عن
مقتل جندي ارمني واصابه اثنين اخرين في
الشبكات الحدوديه مع القوات الاذربيجانيه
عبر وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين امير عبد
الله هيان عن امله في ان تشهد العلاقات
بين طهران والقاهره انفتاحا جديا مؤكدا في
تصريحات لوكاله ايرنا الايرانيه ان هناك
حوارا جاريا مع مصر في هذا الصدر
بالطبع تبذل بعض دول جهودا لتشجيع مصر
وايران على تحسين العلاقات ولطالما رحبن
بذلك حاليا يعقد رؤساء وكالاتنا ومكاتب
حمايه المصالح لدينا في طهران والقاهره
اجتماعات جيده هناك وصول جيد الى السلطات
في البلدين نامل ان نشهد خطوات جديده
ومتبادله لتطوير العلاقات مع مصر الشقيقه
والصديقه التي نعطيها الاولويه للعلاقات
معها هذا البلد مهم في سياستنا الخارجيه
تصريحات وزير الخارجيه الايراني سبقها
اشارات اخرى لرغبه طهران في تطبيع
علاقاتها مع القاهره حيث قال عضو لجنه
الامن القومي في البرلمان الايراني فدا
حسين مالكي قال ان هناك توقعات بعوده
العلاقات مع مصر في المستقبل القريب واضاف
ان المفاوضات الجاريه في العراق مع مصر
تجري بشكل ايجابي وانه من المتوقع افتتاح
السفرات في كلا البلدين قريبا على ان
يعاقبها ترتيب لقاء بين الرئيسين المصري
والايراني
لمزيد من المتابعه حول هذا الموضوع معي من
القاهره الان الدكتور محمد عباس ناجي وهو
رئيس تحرير مجله مختارات ايرانيه دكتور
محمد اهلا وسهلا بك هل الظروف مئاتيه
وناضجه لاعاده العلاقات الدبلوماسيه كامله
بين القاهره
و طهران والمقطوعه منذ اكثر من 44 عاما
وما هي شروط القاهره لهذه العوده برايك
اهلا وسهلا بك اعتقد ان هناك اجواء جديده
في منطقه الشرق الاوسط تطيح القول بانه
بعض دول في المنطقه بدات تنظر برؤيه
مختلفه تجاه علاقتها مع قوه رئيسيه في
المنطقه هناك اتجاه نحو التهدئه على مستوى
منطقه الشرق الاوسط بشكل عام وهذا اتضح
حتى من تحركات ايران ودول مثل تركيا في
النهايه لكن الحديث عن عوده قريبه
للعلاقات مع مصر اعتقد سابق لاوانه لانه
في النهايه هناك في هناك حاجه الى مزيد من
الوقت لوضع النقاط فوق الاحرف وتحديد مدى
امكانيه التوافق على الملفات التي تحظى
باهتمام مشترك ما بين طهران والقاهره
وفيما يتعلق بسؤالك مدى او تقييم مدى
استيعاب ايران لرؤيه مصر للعلاقات بين
الطرفين ما يتعلق بعدم التدخل في الشؤون
الداخليه واحترام الاخر وتوازن المصالح
الموقف الايراني من بعض الملفات التي تحظى
باهتمام خاص من جانب مصر على غرار الملف
الفلسطيني والتدخلات الاقليميه الايرانيه
في منطقه شرق الاوسط بشكل عام طيب حاليا
المصالحه الايرانيه السعوديه وكذلك
المصالحه مع سوريا وعوده سوريا للجامعه
العربيه تسرع برايك من امكانيه عوده
العلاقات
الى سابق عهدها بين طهران والقاهره يعني
انه في انعكاس ايجابي على كل هذه التحولات
على هذا الملف ايضا
يعني انا في اعتقادي المهم الان هو تقييم
سلوك ايران وانا اعتقد انه هذا السلوك هو
موضع اختبار حقيقي هل سيكون لدى ايران نيه
حقيقيه في ان تغير مواقفها وسياساتها في
المنطقه
وتستوعب تحفظات بعض الدول الرئيسيه في
المنطقه على هذه السياسات ومدى امكانيه ان
تتجاوب مع الجهود المبذوله للوصول الى
تسويات سياسيه لبعض الازمات الاقليميه في
المنطقه التي تحظى باهتمام خاص من جانب
دول مثل مصر والسعوديه وغيرها اعتقد انه
هذا هو الاهم الان قبل ان يكون هناك مجال
للحديث عن علاقات دبلوماسيه من القاهره
الدكتور محمد عباس ناجي رئيس تحرير مجله
مختارات ايرانيه شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المشاركه
الى افغانستان الان حيث تتزايد الانقسامات
بين قاده حركه طالبان فقد ذكرت مصادر
للعربيه من داخل الحكومه ان وزير الداخليه
سراج الدين حقاني ذهب اواخر الشهر الماضي
الى ما اقل قياده الحركه في ولايه قندهار
للقاء زعيمها هبه الله اخوان زاده الا انا
زعيم طالبان رفض لقاء حقا فيما انتقد وزير
الداخليه الطلبان زعيم الحركه بشكل غير
مباشر عده مرات بسبب ما اسماه احتكار
السلطه وتشويه سمعه النظام وكانت مصادر
العربيه قد ذكرت في وقت سابق ان حقاني
يسعى الى تشكيل مجلس للحكم داخل الحركه
ضمن سعيه الى تقييد سلطات زعيم طالبان وقد
شدد حقاني على انه لو كان زعيم الحركه
الروحي الملا عمر على قيد الحياه لما كان
يفكر البته في تعيين خمسه من اصدقائه فقط
في الحكومه في انتقاد موجه الى زعيم
الحركه بعد تاسيسه
قوه امنيه خاصه من المقربين منه ومن ابناء
قبيلته
بعد فراق استمر لاكثر من ثلاثين عاما تمكن
المواطن السعودي تركي خالد السنيد بمساعده
سفاره بلاده في مصر من لقاء والدته
المصريه التي كانت قد انفصلت عن ابيه
وانقطعت اخبارها منذ ذلك الحين واوضح
اسناد انه افترق عن والدته قبل 32 عاما
حيث عادت امه الى بلادها دون ان يراها ولو
لمره واحده لم يتخلى السنيد عن حلمه بلقاء
والدته حيث سعى لذلك لسنوات طويله واخيرا
كان لقاء الذي انهى كل سنين الفراق
اكننا في حلم يعني شعور فرحه مع ان انا مش
مصدقه ده فعلا حقيقه يعني ده انا مش دي
حقيقه اللي بتحصل دي مش مصدقه لا انا شفت
مراته بشكر بشكر مراته بشكر وشفت ابنه
شفتهم يعني كده في التليفون انما ما
قابلتهمش
شعور يعني الحمد لله او بالبدايه ما كنت
مصدق هل انا هو حلم او انه صح او انه مو
بهذا الشيء لكن الحمد لله اني وصلت لعند
طريق السفاره السعوديه
جهزوا كل شيء بالنسبه لي لهم فضل كبير بعد
الله للوصول الى الوالده انا كنت ابحث قبل
كنت ابحث قبل لكن ما قدرت اوصل يعني كلها
من كلام وكنت ابحث من عنده قاربي ما حد
وصلني لها فاضطريت اني اروح للسفاره فما
لي حل للسفاره
جميل جدا وقد يجمع الله الشتيتين بعدما
يظنني كل الظن ان لا تلاقي اعزائي
المشاهدين قبل ان اختم نشره الخامسه نتابع
واياكم هذه الصور المباشره لعمليات فرز
الاصوات في الانتخابات التركيه
حيث اغلقت مكاتب الاقتراع منذ بعض الوقت
وسترقب الجميع للنتائج الاوليه للانتخابات
التي سيتم اعلانها مساء اليوم
اطيب التحيات والى اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات